um my name is Hylton can't be shocked
I'm nine years old - no no sir look man
I was like yo man I'm n years old the
best thing about being a boy is look a
boy be very sporty the best thing being
a girl it's pick is because that girls
can do a little bit more things than
boys can that is another cool thing the
best thing about being a girl is now I
don't have to pretend to be a boy the
other day yeah I love them before I
transitioned I was just pretending to be
a boy but now I'm a girl and I'm a lot
happier where I'm gonna go come on I
know the worst thing about being a girl
is that you just can't do things that
boys can do the worst thing about being
a boy y'all under armpit stench like it
kind of bothers me how there was not one
girl president one thing I wish I could
do when I can because I'm a girl is bra
die be the just for some trauma surgeon
yeah godson Jim I can't be treated like
I wanted to Toledo ha hey Bob Sapp Hawk
knock on door see I was shaking my
buttocks some poker was your finish the
audition if I was a girl my life would
be very strange and odd I wouldn't be
one of those fancy girls are in just me
like a tomboy the hell it comes in your
face it's very very
dating with long hair and the boys teach
about not learning for us we keep
pattern you can send your crap if I was
a girl and I don't have to play Barbies
Papa Diana but I think back and I won't
be able to play boy games I don't know
boss trippin evolve and say glad
something that makes me sad is thinking
of my dad I used to go to my dad's house
and then one day he left me on the porch
I got bullied before us and then after
that I never saw okay
he's just pushed me against a wall
didn't left it though it seemed sorry
and I saw had a rehearsal I don't know
but I do miss Shehata
measures looking at submission of the
moon every night if I could change one
of the world's I would stop people from
bowling well yeah but I know my dad I'm
a little I would make the roads able to
fit for her so there would be less
traffic and I have if I did feel a
diamond shows on my photo except with us
in your bag with that I'm a pioneer
mushroom well I actually got a little
sugar I would not change anything
because I like what I have and when I
a chocolate house I would live in that
house and I would eat it every day so
you have to appreciate what you have
then what you don't have
when I grow up I want to be a
professional golfer today the first
Indian president want to be a Navy SEAL
I got everyone to that it's not bad I
might even come I guess I prefer sort of
just Abbott's to do I'm in Indonesia I
want to be a dentist pager or computer
like genius guy move the middle simply
seem to the dirt repeats I am going to
help kids have good teeth not have
cavities
[Music]
what can go up but never come down the
answer is H because you can grow but you
cannot get smaller so do they say better
sounds like bitter
[Music]
what do you think about girls what what
shoes the chickens weigh the answers we
Bock Bock Bock Bock
[Music]
boy
[Music]
how many photos it we take 300 and no I
think it's like sort of like 420 in that
range
[Music]
you